Philadelphia da Larry crasner has made
it clear that his top priority is
protecting the city's criminals rather
than its law-abiding citizens that's bad
enough in the abstract but it's easy to
forget that this policy has real victims
it has destroyed the lives of real
people Michael White stabbed Sean skel
injure to death allegedly after gloating
online that he was about to quote cut
someone despite that and there's no
dispute about it he did it
krasner would not even charged with
homicide the case was weakened by that
so badly that white in the end wound up
with just probation
now last week Philadelphia's chest on
Hill College invited both krasner and
white to it's quote transforming justice
Conference white was used as an example
a standout example of criminal justice
reform
Linda Challenger is the mother of the
murdered man Sean scavenger she recently
spoke with us about all this I'm sorry
about this and I can't imagine what it
must be like for you to see the man who
murdered your son held up as a hero what
is it like outrageous that's the word
that comes to mind it is really
outrageous they're parading this person
around as an example of criminal justice
reform it is appalling to me
that they would do such a thing
obviously not understandable went to a
conference on Friday for criminal
justice Larry crasner was speaking my
intention was to see what Larry had to
say have an open mind about these things
and to my surprise when I got there
Michael white my son's killer was on the
agenda to speak on a panel outrageous
it's hard to understand it is outrageous
but it's also confusing what was the
point of this why would the kawah
college administrators allow this to
happen you know I am NOT certain that
the college was actually aware of what
was happening at least what they
presented to me was that they were not
aware that Michael white was who he was
and that he was put on this panel he did
not end up
actually speaking because at the
eleventh hour they decided to change
that agenda up and put two gentlemen who
had been in prison for a very long time
and had apparently not committed the
murders that they were accused of many
many years ago obviously to people that
you know would warrant speaking on a
panel like that rather than putting
someone like Michael White up to make a
mockery of the criminal justice reform
that would be going on I I completely
can't understand it except a political
agenda by Larry Krasner and the defense
attorney Kerr Bradford gray it's just
this is your second time on our show
we're happy to have you back this murder
took place in public the man who stabbed
your son to death and they'd never met
before who stabbed him to death later
wrote a rap song about it I mean there's
really there's no question that he did
it so given that would you say to larry
Krassner who's bragging about getting in
effect getting this guy off for your
son's murder what would you say to him I
would say you are an evil and very sick
man I mean it literally rises to that
level this is not just a disagreement
around prosecutors strategy or something
like that I think I had mentioned to you
before I believe that he obstructed
justice and that's exactly what happened
there's zero question that Michael
plunged a knife into my son's back with
eyewitnesses surrounding him on a lovely
evening in July none zero so this was
theater at its best this was completely
orchestrated by Larry krasner right from
the beginning and it continues to be
astounding I mean this panel discussion
that they were going to put this person
on and if I can even call him a person
he's a murderer is again I keep using
the word outrageous because it is so
beyond my understanding of anything that
makes any good common logical sense
right so they can stab your son to death
in the middle of Rittenhouse Square and
then in effect mock him and you in
public that's what Larry Krasner's doing
III hope that you get justice in this
case
I really do what I hope you'll come back
and tell us about thank you for joining
us and for that update I appreciate it
thank you
[Music]